[Musique]
Donc cette valeur
de la dehors
Plus de 120 mille personnes depuis le tremblement de terre
Nous avons reçu des candidatures et maintenant nous
nous regroupons
Encore une fois, nous donnerons la priorité au risque.
Le risque se situe désormais principalement après 2000
Mais nous l'achetons aussi pour les bâtiments
Nos interventions portent sur des bâtiments avant 2000
commencera pendant et continuera après
Nous les inclurons dans le système
Et chaque jour, chaque heure. En fait, ça augmente
Ces applications vont
[Musique]
Effectuer le test est pour notre sécurité
Il est important au moins lorsque le tremblement de terre frappe
Il n’est pas clair si nous serons pris.
Nous sommes assis dedans maintenant tout seul
Par exemple, nous faisons confiance à certaines choses, mais
Nous ne pouvons pas convaincre les enfants, alors nous
Si le test dit qu'il est fiable, vous l'aimez.
Nous irons heureux et confortablement
nous vivrons dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
Il contient du matériel d'urgence
Ouvrons-en un, celui-ci si vous voulez.
notre modèle économique
Nous avons un collier cervical en cas d'urgence.
Nous avons du matériel d'aide
Il existe des sauveurs comme les lampes de poche, les sifflets et l’eau.
sois honnête à partir d'ici
Nous pouvons l'observer en venant dans notre établissement.
les gens peuvent avoir des idées et de l'aide
Vous pouvez acheter des produits et organiser des ensembles
Ces demandes ne s'améliorent pas chaque jour
Nous rencontrons le but ici est entièrement
ils attendent
[Musique]